all right taste buddies May 10th if you
haven't marked it on your calendar yet
do it we are doing our first ever live
streaming taste buds and we are putting
all the pieces together right now most
likely will be a live venue in New York
City as well as live streaming there is
going to be a ton of surprises there is
going to be the craziest battle you've
ever seen surprise guests it's going to
be a super-sized long episode it's going
to be a ton of fun you guys wanted this
for so long we're so excited to do it
for you people have been sending in
artwork poster work for the battles
we've loved it keep sending them in we
will post them
and now to the dates you can see me live
right now with the Impractical Jokers
we're on tour go to
impracticaljokerslive.com for tickets uh
and if you don't see your city we're
adding them all the way through the end
of the year but for right now we got
Bangor Maine and Boston April 27 28th
and 29th we added a show at the Wang
theater there's still tickets available
for that
West Valley City Utah the Maverick
Center and the Bellco Theater in Denver
May 5th and 6th then we're off to Texas
May 19 20 and 21 we're in Arlington
we're in Austin and we are in Sugarland
Texas
kick it over to June guys we got
Columbus Cleveland and Detroit on June
2nd 3rd and 4th Minneapolis Des Moines
and Kansas City on June 15th 16th and
17th I believe Joe
DeRosa might be coming to one of these
I'm not sure which July 27th and 28th
and 29th Nashville Indianapolis and St
Louis two in St Louis we added one there
so there's still tickets there and uh
look for this the dates to the end of
the year they're all coming and
practicaljokerslive.com new episodes of
jokers is on Thursday night at 10
o'clock on TBS and True TV we're in
season 10 right now throw that on your
DVR love you guys we'll see you Live May
10th
here
coming up
on First and 22nd in Columbus Ohio uh
and then back again at the crane theater
May 3rd uh all of these shows will be I
Never Promised You a Rose Garden come on
out folks we're real excited uh go to
jodorosinfo.com for all ticket dates
tickets uh show information ticket links
you want to buy tickets whatever you
need it's all there uh and also if
you're in New York Joey Rose is open
seven days a week sandwiches drinks good
times come through
bugs they come into the mic talking
about the food they hate talking about
the food they like two Fool's gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they come folks
welcome to
g-a-s-t-e today we are battling three
ways with our special guest Sam talent I
thought you were gonna forget my last
name no okay no but I know what a fun
way to start in that moment I did
realize how weird your name is is that a
real name t-a-l-l-e-n-t is that real
that's your real last name it's some
Scots Irish bastardization that's
unbelievable
well thank you it really does help it's
but you sound like an urban comic
actually I wished yeah yeah so don't we
all yeah I'd be like who that boy run he
talking
two L's though which is fun which also
makes it is your own spin on it yeah
yeah that's my name man that's why his
name my grandfather's name what is your
uh the origin 75 Scott's Irish 25 secret
Mexican oh what secret Mexican mean they
came in they were allowed and it's not
good oh no they like lived in caves in
New Mexico and were unaware that they
were in America until like a census
worker told them in the early 1900s I
haven't heard of this yeah yeah but they
were talking people mule leaders that
kind of thing that's fascinating yeah
wow did you do you do you feel like you
can identify with that part of you at
all have you sought out anything in the
family or like it's just my grandma was
like she forgot Spanish on purpose she
called it a dog tongue and she said the
only good thing about being Mexican is
you don't get poison ivy and mosquitoes
leave you alone
wait
rub it down right now grab some leaves
that's so weird are you serious
why is that not known by everybody
sounds like a racist thing why does it
sound racing sounds like a superpower to
me you could run through the brush
on a ticks it sounds weirdly right so
what was the other thing that you don't
get mosquitoes leave me alone I couldn't
make that sound I could make that sound
racist yeah yeah I could as well so
let's hear it
say something about Mexican people
Mexican people uh have some of my
favorite Cuisine can't even get poison
ivy you know
[Laughter]
it sounded like you envied them uh is it
is the reason they can't get poison ivy
and the reason that mosquitoes leave you
alone stem from the same thing I think
it's something in the blood is what my
grandmother said again she was a 90 year
old woman who looked like a calzone you
know what I mean she was just like a
sunken doe of a woman but it was brown
and burnt and she was deeply horrified
of her uh ethnic history is that right
yeah so my grandma Lydia is my only
living um grandparent I love her so much
she's 92. yeah and sometimes she'll be
like ah you know Puerto Rican people but
she's 100 Puerto Rican oh yeah so there
you go yeah I think she just means like
I don't know what the [__] she means
actually she's probably at an age where
she's forgotten that she's Porter
race
she freaks out of the parade
uh today we're doing
this is a this is an interesting one
today uh speaking of
uh barrels you mentioned barrels earlier
uh we're doing uh Sonic the Hedgehog
versus Super Mario
versus Donkey Kong
are arguably the top three video game
icons ever got other video game icons
you've got your crash bandicoots all
right your vector mans your vector man
yes let's talk about this your Samus is
from Metroid but no how do you say Metro
he's touching these three these three
your Yoshi's your your curves but these
yeah but you got no Yoshi and Kirby
without Mario and might I say you got no
Mario without Donkey Kong but that's
I'll hold off well he was named Jumpman
originally uh you know that's the kind
of thing I know it wasn't Mario though
he was originally called Jump Man
called Mario if you read the directions
for Donkey Kong like how to play on the
machine yeah on the original machine
where it was printed the rules or
whatever if you go to the Library of
Congress yeah yeah and you get the
manual yeah
on the weekends you used to have text on
the on the on the next to the screen on
the panel and it would tell you how to
play because it was like you know you're
walking up to a thing in public you know
what I mean I don't know yeah and it
would say it would say control jump man
that was that was what they called them
yeah but we know who he was did you also
know this about Donkey Kong Donkey Kong
was originally that Nintendo wanted to
make a game about Popeye yes they did
they weren't allowed to do it well they
didn't date Capcom made it but yeah but
they weren't allowed to do it so they
made Donkey Kong and then Donkey Kong I
believe faced some uh further potential
legal issues because of King Kong yes
well I think Donkey Kong Won that battle
I think they did still with us today and
he's had children he's still with us
today and where is King Kong I haven't
heard from him it's been a while
no Kong Skull Island that's that's a
rebooted Series right now it's a good
point yeah
uh I am team well of course I'm gonna
take the underdog I'm team Sonic you're
you're in an open grave and we're
thinking do you think Sonic is even an
underdog compared to Donkey Kong I think
Donkey Kong's the biggest on the door if
you feel like people I'll get into what
I think people's problems with Sonic are
gonna be okay uh it's also going to be a
lot of my defense the reasons I defend
Sonic okay uh Sam is taking the easy you
know
America
how are you doing food this
tell that as a gigantic pant load of a
man and we're in here talking about dork
[__] we would have time to guess I'm
grateful to be here
he said when you texted him a bunch of
different things he said you had strong
opinions against Sonic so we thought
that was good to do Sonic man UK your
food you're like I like this a lot I
like this weird fruit
yeah what is that black pudding fruit
what is that you've seen that thing
where they scrape it out and it looks
like a gelatinous custard and it's like
no like muddy black no no I didn't even
I thought you misspelled something yeah
yeah you were like strange cheese is
that string cheese no Joe Galactic
tongue no Oh I thought it was string
wanted me to figure out what strange
cheese man yeah is that just your
opinion of which cheeses are odd looks
like Roquefort blue cheese you know like
oh so you can't read it
I forgot who I was talking to so it's
not called strange cheese that's just
you saying
odd Jesus I'm othering the cheese okay
guys it's not your parmesan or string
cheese and I was like string cheese is
good it's so cheese is fine it's so
weird um it's for children for babies
strange cheese is a weird thing to say
to respond with when I say what are your
deal breakers yeah you go love strange
cheese I do love strange cheese and
tendons you strange do you thinking
Swiss for all I know because you think
Swiss is weird because it's got holes in
it it's very condescending I know well
you're looking down upon me I am the
heel of this podcast yeah I'll tell you
what a high five from over here I saw
the list eggplants I'm at the top of my
I keep trying to get him to do an
eggplant sandwich
I love a good night's shade oh dude
Tomatoes yeah come on yeah it doesn't
get better than a nice beef steak with a
style mozzarella Professor food a little
bit of Basil olive oil wait I think
you're talking about eggs salt and
pepper
eggplant is so overrated
you're overrated it can be meat yeah
then you're an eggplant how about that I
think that's a slur racial yeah
who's projecting that on I mean I think
you're an overrated Jokers got canceled
yeah
Antiquated slurs eggplant is a water
white secretly Egyptian yeah I know
it's a watery vegetable I always because
I
because deeply exploiting do you know
how bad I want to just tell people I'm
Egyptian to help me get jobs I know yeah
and I never went with it so now if I do
it now it's too late yeah and now you're
appropriating your own culture
my big life was when I I filed for
financial aid College I didn't check
Latino oh geez I'm half and I didn't
check it I just like I play White you
know so I checked white and then all of
a sudden I thought it was my casting
yeah
eggplant's a watery vegetable and
there's nothing more disappointing than
slicing into what you think is chicken
or veal parmesan and finding out it's
eggplant too dumb to know what you
ordered yeah that's good that is a sad
life sometimes sometimes you go to a
tray at a party for instance
parties I'm sorry I will give you I will
give you an eggplant Parmesan that will
change your life yeah
actually my buddy Tim Dylan is a foodie
if you will we've had him we've had many
you've had many a meal together and I
turned Tim on to a friend of mine uh Dom
de bartellameo Domenico's Foods uh out
in in California Beverly Hills wine and
cheese shop go check them out my boy I
love Dom yeah you know Dom's through me
I do and the other day he goes he
messaged me and he goes he goes
I think I think I forgot to respond I
was doing the sandwich Summit in Austin
the thing I do at South by Southwest and
he goes uh you know maybe you think of
your boy and I was like Dom you don't
live in Austin right or own a shop in
Austin right I don't think he understood
what it was well let me tell you
something right now you have that that
man's eggplant parm I'm sure it's great
melt in your mouth unbelievable it's so
thin it's paper thin but layered
interesting I'm sure it's great so nice
talking huh well I assume it would be
thicker if it didn't become the mess
that he's describing now this is I'm
telling you it eats well it slices well
like a nice thin eggplant parm baba
ganoush is where I'm coming from
the number one dip there is okay get
well he just he just battled hummus
versus onion dip we just found a second
did you hear what he just said yeah you
don't agree with that the number one dip
there is yeah no you don't I don't agree
with you yeah he could have been in here
for the last battle it was becomes
versus onion dip I heard you guys
screaming at each other like they turned
the lights off and put the tasers on the
table I mean look yeah we can we can
switch gears right now and go and have a
[__] no no we're here we're here we
already tweeted it it doesn't matter we
can do that another time
tweet it out you could tweet it right
now we'll go eggplant because I got a
lot to say about goddamn egg you know
eggplant yay or nay people are gonna yay
eggplant yeah you're not gonna name it
well let's give it a shot and see but
everyone's automatic loss for you why
don't we just stay in the pocket stay in
the pocket this is interesting to me
actually because Sonic is is very
relevant right now Mario's very relevant
relevant right yeah captured the
Zeitgeist yeah yeah the people can't
quit talking about Sonic out there well
it wasn't part two just released wasn't
the movie just released six months ago
eight months ago yeah but it did they
did banging numbers right it did to his
[__] compared to one which lost 150
million dollars
no the first Sonic did really well yeah
it was terrible well right now Mario
here we are Mario is controversial and
relevant right now I will say Donkey
Kong is neither and I know where my
place is in this conversation but maybe
I play spoiler yeah wait a second though
you you said you brought up
and Tim knows his food and Tim will tell
you that his eggplant because you said
your friends you know Tim I had a funny
Tim Dylan asked him about Dom's eggplant
yeah I will that's you know what he'll
say yeah 30 minutes in a row of words
Tim Tim and I not that we be
disconnected but we sort of reconnected
recently we were talking on the phone a
decent amount and like really getting
into like some Tim J Dillon yeah yeah
and uh the other day I talked to him and
I said I'm thinking I'm thinking about
buying a house and he went on a thing
about how the power grids were gonna die
yeah it's never enough lifting
conversation should we get him on the
phone yeah
it went sideways I was like oh my God
it's Bleak man he's a gray cloud what do
you want what do we want what do you
want to ask him I'll ask him about baba
ganoush all right don't ask me about
video games he'll call us all the r word
[Laughter]
when I asked him about Bob's she
forwards your call I will laugh very
hard
I mean if it's not busy he should pick
up yeah exactly there's a hierarchy
Timothy
hello hey babe how you doing
good how are you good I miss you I
missed the sound of your voice I miss
you or you guys very good very good
um I'm called this is so believe it or
not I have been thinking of you and I
have wanted to call but your name just
came up I'm with Sam Town Joe DeRosa
we're on the pod
you know we're talking about food and
your name came up because baba ganoush
came up
yeah and we wanted a couple things a
couple things came up Tim yeah what
triggered the phone call Tim was I said
I I've been talking to you on the phone
a lot lately and we've had some nice
conversations
and and I said the other day I asked him
about what that I said I might buy a
house and you told me how the power
grids were gonna go down
by the way I I am I'm I'm I I own a
house though over there
yeah
[Music]
it doesn't fail by him
what'd he say
it's like if you live in a nice area I'm
lost in the Power Group doesn't really
fail it fails in areas that aren't as
expensive right yeah but you have houses
in every expensive area there is
I know
he's saying he'll be fine where he lives
because he bought Oh I thought I thought
this is rich areas whereas I would be
forced to buy oh in a more impoverished
area and would suffer a power grid so
you know you're making that assumption
that that's what I meant
are they are they going down as as some
sort of they're not going down but
in Tim's reality
Joe's paying more than any other club in
America
um the talent at that club right now far
exceeds probably any other club in
America The Comedy Store is limping
um he has done what he said he was going
to do and more I'd be like it is not me
but amazing to watch
Tim
Tim I wasn't referring specifically to
our conversation I was just saying it
was funny that I said I might buy a
house and you said the power grids were
gonna go down Tim's going now into the
worth of Austin as a city of what's
happened
that you know me and a lot of people I
talk to have plans we're going to put
chips in everybody we're gonna make sure
we all right we watch out for everybody
well I still get spots at Rogan's Club
all of the mothership acts we're all
going to get a chip in us so that we
never relate to our spots
you and I will be tables at Rogan's Club
people will be eating off of our back
all right yeah yeah we'll be on all
fours I always said I always said when
the [__] went down like I wouldn't
murder anybody when the [__] went down
like the vampires took over I would be
the guy that helped the vampire oh yeah
I'd sell out immediately I'd be the guy
going I'd rather be a slave than food if
I could interrupt the sun coming we have
him live on oh sorry Tim Tim anyway
we're battling today on tastebunchpad
Super Mario versus Donkey Kong versus
Sonic the Hedgehog do you have any
thoughts
yes
um I loathe you know the way I feel
about Italians I like their food but I
feel like they
you know what I mean let's just say that
now I equate each one of these
characters to a race go
sh oh hello really
thank you Tim that's me but we really
called you because we really called you
because we wanted your side thoughts on
baba ganoush and I wanted you to speak a
little bit about Dominic uh Dom
dipatoma's eggplant Tim by the way I
know this is uh just a nuisance for you
but I think I was bombing the first 10
minutes so bad they put you on the horn
all right
you did great you did great thank you
for coming hey I'll see you guys later
yeah
Philly helium April 19th is
some of the greatest eggplant it's
phenomenal yes uh
Blue Hills cheese shop I'm a big fan of
Dom uh he's a great guy
and he single-handedly made me lose no
weight living in California everyone
else has lost tremendous amounts of
weight
um
I like it but I gotta be honest
the variance between good baba ganoush
and unedible
is very large it's a matter of time
um if it's really good it's great if
it's not as good it's very skippable and
I gotta be honest it's just never going
to be hummus
because what you just said I applied a
hummus actually Tim I was team hummus
last episode and I lost to onion dip
that's insane what the [__] I know oh I
can't believe it God I can't believe it
I I like this I think hummus is the
standard bearer of Middle Eastern dips
yeah I think baba ganoush can be very
very good but a lot of times it's you
know kind of lackluster I agree
um
looks like
it it should be a dollop in the middle
of a bowl of hummus it should be a thing
that you drag in if you want it it does
not function well on its own uh and it's
a disgusting looking dip too I mean baba
ganoush is gross looking I mean look Tim
would you would you but you don't think
that sometimes hummus takes like it
takes like some bad hummus it smells and
tastes like edible vomit
here's the thing with hummus
um obviously it is for the most part
flavored
this is the thing with hummus okay baba
ganoush is never flavored so baba
ganoush relies on only the strength of
the Baba Ganesh hummus could be flavored
with many different things it's a it's a
to me hummus's paint is white paint uh
you you add the colors you choose the
palette
um and I you know very important all you
do is plain hummus obviously that's very
good
um but I I you know every every time
I've had hummus I think I'm more
I'm I gotta throw my hat in in the
hummus ring over Baba Ganesh baba
ganoush should I get nervous when I'm
about to eat it I get nervous I'm never
nervous around hummus
I agree I love it you you have to come
on the on the POD live one time buddy I
really want to come on the Pod I told
you the rose of this a big guy big black
guy what nothing that matters but it's
funnier if I tell you the truth he
walked across the street to me in
Raleigh North Carolina he goes hey man
when we go get you on taste buds I swear
to God no way that's hysterical it's
hysterical well all right I will let you
go buddy I love you I'll call you just
for a regular chat
thank you so much uh all right I'll talk
to you I'll give you a ring thank you
okay babe
we're joined today by Sam talents on the
pot yeah
I still vote we stay on this eggplant
and just make it a discussion we've got
the pulls up the polls are up the people
we have plenty of time let's start the
battle we actually do need to get to the
back all right let's do it all right
folks Sam we start this with a chant
okay uh It Goes b-a-t-t-l-e Buzz you can
do it with us if you want okay ready
time two
b-a-t-t-l-e books all right the three
video game icons Mario Sonic Donkey Kong
Sam is our guest we will give you
opening argument
uh there is a long storied history of
the Japanese thank you very much
I thought you're gonna bring it back to
eggplant oh good sorry no no the
Japanese misrepresenting other cultures
is always hilarious and uh exciting all
right and you can take it all the way
back to their uh well I don't want to
say there but a general disdain for
Koreans after certain war crimes were
committed both ways and now the fact
that they gave us their idea of what an
Italian is has delighted generations of
people for about 40 years now all right
the gameplay of Mario has defined the
side scroller and then in the Nintendo
64 series when they became the 360
degree open world romp that that game
was has now been popularized and
bastardized by most other gaming series
to this day so Mario
was it two or three Super Mario World
was the magnum opus uh
Super Mario Brothers for Nintendo I'm
more of a Super Nintendo guy well but
yes
well I don't know
Super Mario World is four it's part four
yes and that's the one where you get the
feather and the hat and you fly about
yes that's also the game that introduced
Yoshi to the world yes uh Super Mario
World in my opinion is the best of the
four Mario games that was really good
too three's fantastic three four four
takes what three did and just enhances
it can I can I love two I love all the
those stuff do you love Mario Brothers I
do because I do because that game is one
of my favorite games I do quite a bit
Yeah so I I would say I I don't think
Mario brought things into the side
scroller genre that that have become
Staples undoubtedly I believe they were
the first one to have the overall world
map where you could go to World Tour
um Zelda uh no well Zelda 2 had an over
world map that you walk through but not
quite like Mary but Mario is like the
he's like a venture capitalist he's he
has now 50 other titles
he's a mogul yeah he's a mogul he's
built an Empire he is he built an Empire
and he is the top dog yeah in 30
franchises yeah we have no marriage
arguably the biggest
video game character across all
platforms and companies like next
what thank you should have been Pac-Man
no Pac-Man is a vestigial tale that
hasn't fallen off American culture
anyway
we have no more how did we not do it so
who cares about Pac-Man
you guys are sentimental for Pac-Man
is in the top five video games I agree
100 yeah if you don't know where the
moon goes in the daytime
yeah if the sun goes away and you go no
no come back it's gonna be cold forever
yeah dude I haven't been stupid right
Miss Pac-Man in my living room and it's
the first thing I ever I I should have
been Miss Pac-Man we [__] up it's all
right we done [__] we have no we have
no Mario without Donkey Kong yeah well
that's my point so guy throw to you now
that's what my that's what my standing
point is is that
Donkey Kong predates everybody and you
mentioned before that Mario was called
Jumpman and Donkey Kong fair enough now
what else was called Jumpman Michael
Jordan Michael Jordan the greatest 2016
player arguably of all time yeah number
23. Okay Christian Leighton or two of
course Christian Lane at two and that's
Duke and NBA yeah okay combination
um I I would say that donkey on did he
did he take a woman and throw her in a
cage and hold it for ransom right yes
who hasn't been there who hasn't been
there who has at least felt like they
wish they could have this woman in their
Captain incarcerate her yeah incarcerate
the woman who hasn't thrown fire bombs
or wanted to at another human being
who's trying to impede on their
territory yeah okay you know what I'm
saying honestly if we're talking
arcade if we're talking video games in
and himself then I go that the
Trailblazer is the upright machine
right and Donkey Kong was even before
Mario Brothers I believe it was Donkey
Kong was the Bruce everything Mario and
Donkey Kong was a Smash Hit I mean when
it got to that level of gaming like you
know there was there was something like
there was like you know much simpler
games before that break out things like
that when it got to this level when you
had your Froggers and your qberts and
your Pac-Mans Donkey Kong was
just King of the mountain as well and I
gotta be honest like it's like when you
if you go back and watch something that
influenced other things you might say 40
years ago someone might watch a movie
from from you know whatever and be like
I I don't get it it's not it's like yeah
but you don't understand in that time it
was the thing why we have this now and
that is what Donkey Kong is to both of
you you don't have either of you you
don't have Mario without Donkey Kong and
you don't have Sonic without Mario
well then that brings me to my Sonic
argument and I know something I'm not
even getting into Donkey Kong Jr yet all
right guys when you were a kid did
someone ever read you the book Everybody
Poops pimp you ever hear about that book
uh I think it's like a way to introduce
kids to the fact that you know
going to the restroom should not be
shameful well many people still have
what they call pooping anxiety
self-controlled constipation or nervous
diarrhea
okay I won't go to the bathroom outside
of my home and uh I
certainly certainly this applies to me
and a lot of it has to do with basically
your gut health and that's why we want
to talk about seeds seeds
ds01 daily symbiotic supports healthy
regularity healthy motility and ease of
the evacuation
there's also increasing research on the
gut brain axis which she is currently
researching a partnership with axial
Therapeutics so it's a one capsule in so
there's a capsule in capsule called via
cap safeguards viability through
digestion for delivery of an average of
100 of the probiotic starting dose to
the colon so a lot of times you take
vitamins and you're not getting all of
it this is a hundred percent the outer
capsule also serves as an elegant
barrier to oxygen moisture and heat so
no Refrigeration is necessary 16 of
their 24 strains are specifically geared
toward Digestive Health that makes sense
people take a probiotic for Digestive
Health
it reinforces healthy stool hydration
which I didn't even know really you
needed and we're learning here it
supports gut ease from occasional
gastrointestinal discomfort associated
with uh where were we there increase
intestinal Transit time I feel smarter
just reading the details of this seed
product uh seeds DSO one daily symbiotic
has four specific probiotic strains that
have been shown to promote healthy skin
and reinforce a healthy gut skin axis so
you get what we're getting at here okay
um
they deliver see delivers a DSO one uh
daily symbiotic to monthly and
sustainable packaging with a reusable
glass jar that protects the probiotics
inside and helps minimize plastic use in
waste maintains heart health maintains
blood cholesterol levels uh already in
the normal range and supports healthy
intestinal recycling of cholesterol and
bile does everything basically so start
a new healthy habit today visit seed.com
taste buds that's and use Coast taste
buds to redeem 25 off your first month
of seeds ds01 daily symbiotic that's
seed.com
s-e-e-d.com slash taste buds and use the
code taste buds try it out I love
butcher box baby premium meals don't
have to come at a premium price butcher
box provides you with the best meat and
seafood on the planet so you can whip up
quality meals on your budget okay the
quality ingredients come to mind yes
they do okay yes they do and so what
about the price points yes they do and
can I ask you what your favorite quality
these are butcher box are because I can
tell you mine yeah please baby
convenience maybe price points as you
said that's exactly the quality as you
said but most important about all the
different cuts taste taste 100 grass
said beef free range organic chicken
pork raised crate free and wild caught
Seafood high quality meat easy to find
seafood you can trust everything she
mainly raised I love books no
antibiotics no hormones okay it's great
I love butcher box I love meat I'm a
meat fan and also by the way if you if
you're gonna do what we're going to tell
you to do you're going to get free
chicken thighs for a year how do you
like that deliver right to your doorstep
it's free shipping always my friends and
you can curate a box and customize it to
your needs you can cancel anytime or you
could take their pre-planned boxes
Quality Meats right to your door frozen
so you can keep them for a nice long
time airtight in the packaging it's the
best get free chicken thighs for a year
and 20 off your first box when you sign
up today how are these people making any
money I don't know that's three pounds
of bone-in chicken thighs free and every
box for a year
plus twenty dollars off your first order
when you sign up at butcherbox.com Taste
Buds and use promo code taste buds claim
this deal at butcherbox.com tastebuds
and use code taste buds
all right I know Sonic will be the
underdog in this but Sonic deserves
leagues of respect Sonic is the only
when I forget the name of the guy that
took over Sega America
uh but everyone forgot his name well
nobody you couldn't his grave is
unmarked yeah yeah but no one says
sunflowers to him
yeah the guy that headed up Sega America
when he was brought in by Japan he had
his only goal was to Dethrone Nintendo
because Nintendo had become so big it
was about to Dr they were about to drop
the Super NES
Sega said we have to step in and be
contenders again in this
um now Nintendo on a side note I'll say
Bravo to that because when Sonic dropped
with Sega I was Fallen yeah so here's
the thing he said Nintendo were real
shitty they were real shitty they they
tried they brought Sega to court trying
to get Sega like they tried to they
Nintendo's real dirty they're like
Disney dirty because they're the best
but here's the thing this guy's only
goal was to Dethrone Nintendo and they
created
a mascot they said we need a mascot that
can rot that's not not just about but
one that can rival Mario they did it
they did it they brought up and and of
course the classic slogan uh Sega does
what Nintendo and the whole thing that's
so I don't know if that's true but
that's very funny it says his
personality was inspired by Bill Clinton
I don't quite get that but Sonic [__]
Sonic
everyone Sonic use that cigar on Tails
yeah yeah but Sonic
all those things that he loses when you
hit him the [__] rings
um Sega does wow
Sega does what Nintendo uh sega's whole
thing was like if you're a little kid go
play Nintendo you want to play with the
big boys you can't play with Sega Mr
marketing it was great marketing second
was a good wave launched the entire tude
era you can you can you can just jump
along
you can
you can get you know you can get
passionate all I'm saying is
a good way to let your friends and
family know your parents were getting
divorced because that was a Hail Mary
pass from dad to the kids to Curry their
favorite good American families with
good values Super Nintendo right there
in front of the TV did they ate dinner
in front of every night as a crew it's a
great place yeah it didn't look like a
divorce oh Sega was like please please
I'm so sorry she didn't mean anything to
me and I can prove that because now
everyone's playing lost Vikings [__]
that Joe defense of Sega in defense of
Sega though I never had to blow into a
tape once that was no no never ever on a
Genesis did anything ever not started no
one was playing those games yeah I had a
Sega Genesis I know look at you now
I active and adopted home yeah you did
yeah you did Joe
I had a Nintendo all right Nintendo and
I went from Nintendo to Sega Genesis
because I could not deny that I said I I
didn't go to Super Nintendo Sega Genesis
came in and they were like do you guys
like metal let's [__] go it was Heavy
Metal it was awesome and so jet black
that was cool he
he Nintendo until the GameCube for
everything that Mario spawns spawned
spanned spawned
um
Sonic did that in the 90s like there
were so many mascots that came after
Sonic yeah uh Crash Bandicoot's a good
example with PlayStation where the whole
thing was like attitude rad like all
that stuff but they tried to do it many
times they also had remember uh was it
Rayman Rayman yeah remember Rayman
that's the thing with Sonic was like
they were like when you like watch like
gaming and stories talk about they talk
about like it was like if you do that
instead of touching women yeah sonic
sonic did this I remember when I
deciding as a kid if you didn't move
yeah for like 30 seconds
that was fun yeah it was an attitude
kind of thing yeah
um yeah you want to read that so
oh in the end sega's only focus was to
compete with its Rivals instead of
fulfilling the user's demand this led to
their downfall that's very true and the
company couldn't keep up with Nintendo
and ultimately failed in its attempt to
conquer the gaming Market how Japanese
they were like if we can't beat our
rival where's sepoku yeah we're on the
steps of the Capitol we're either gonna
[__] do this or we're gonna kill
ourselves live on TV and that's what
they did when they put out the Sega CD
yes that's so funny yeah that Sega CD
was a what was that the Sega Saturn as
well well no there's the screencast what
happened there was this yeah nothing
took there's Sega CD and then Sega 32x
and then Sega Saturn they released all
three of those so close together they
cannibalized each other it was a big
mistake and then they came out the
Dreamcast the dream they're all three of
those systems are good Saturn is a great
system the Dreamcast is an excellent
Dreamcast was good but it just didn't
they they never winter nights on
Dreamcast you want to talk about the two
biggest bonehead moves in gaming history
I do in Home console history here we go
give it to us what I just said Sega did
was a huge one because it led to the
downfall of Sega being its own console
brand and led to them now making games
for basically for Nintendo right yeah
there's no Sega product right now right
platform No in fact the Nintendo switch
with the gaming online thing includes
Sega Genesis streaming which is really
spiking the football yeah that is you
know what I mean yeah yeah yeah Nintendo
put its finger right through sega's belt
loop yes you're mine come over here yeah
yeah uh give me your shoes Sega but
their
bonus only to be rivaled by Nintendo's
move
they were in bed with Sony the
PlayStation was supposed to be a
Nintendo Sony product Nintendo screwed
over Sony so he went go f yourselves
dropped the PlayStation Nintendo drops
the N64 and the rest is history yes
PlayStation was like take care of
yourself but I do think bonehead well
what sells more right now is it the
PlayStation or is it the Nintendo
Nintendo the switch is great I mean the
Wii and the switch kind of turned it
around
I got them all I got them all I got news
for you you still have a hard time
finding a PS5 in a store right now yeah
you still have a hard time but without
is that manufacturing's fault or demand
look it could be Market it could be a
lot well let's just see right now what
sells more is it the PlayStation uh or
is it the yeah the switch look it up I
think the PlayStation but Nintendo is
innovating man the Wii came out you know
and the motion sensor and now the now
the switch take it with you we was a big
moment for them Nintendo has Nintendo is
in an is in they went through a dark
stage with 64 and GameCube GameCube is a
great system I like the game 64 was a
big deal yeah 64 was but it got smart it
got destroyed GameCube in 64 got smoked
by PlayStation and Xbox by PlayStation
2. there was a brief PlayStation
4. 64 had double the amount of numbers
of the PlayStation no way that's
PlayStation 2. it was called 64. the
other one was 32. no no your PlayStation
2 dominated yeah it's [__]
the PlayStation is a better console
PlayStation was 32-bit PlayStation was
CD Nintendo was 64 still cartridge and I
as and as a boy who was then and saved
up all of his money to get that N64 I
never had any issues and that stuff
because it was smooth smooth it wasn't
all polygonal polygonal 64. no 64 was a
lot smoother than PlayStation one
PlayStation
one PlayStation two it ended everything
yeah can the guy who actually still owns
and plays both of these concerts I own
them today speak in on this you're wrong
of the PlayStation are better than the
N64 Graphics they just are no they're
not dude it's
had smoother Graphics over all the PS1
games had better texture textures that
texture is going to take you a lot
farther than smoother what word did I
use smooth much like a good baba ganoush
let's just change it to eggplant the
textures that were applied to the shapes
within PS1 games were more realistic
again a lot of this is because ps1's
hardware specs and triangle polygons
made it easier for third-party
development is that a side-by-side
comparison right there
we could have argued systems even but
but let's just try to refocus look at
look at the you could you yes the the
N64 is a sharper picture and look at the
look at the detail of the PlayStation
there's a crowd in the PlayStation
Stadium on the racing game there's the
other one looks like it looks like
nothing it's like they might have had
more time to smooth it over interesting
it's like they have better graphics no
no no it's like they were able to take
the game you got so many more finally
grass in a video game this is such a
weak argument no no I'm right
here's the thing uh let's get back to
the to the to the uh icons at hand that
we're arguing here sorry you also had
don't
I I love all three of these guys so much
sure uh more than I love the people in
this room good uh
nasty thing to say nasty no but uh dude
they're his real friends don't forget
about Donkey Kong Country Country the
answer is calls Donkey Kong Country on
N64 I mean I'm sorry Super Nintendo was
a late release in the super Nintendo's
lifespan and that massive pushed all the
hardware limits of the Super Nintendo
was pre-rendered Graphics yeah which
country was a revolution and I played it
all the time
and baby donkey the junior was a diddy
I mean you got a whole you got a whole
flight of Donkey Kongs well there was
not many there were only three I didn't
appreciate it was Junior and then donkey
on three Duncan three is very forgiving
on Country yes country but you know what
with Sonic with Sonic though I didn't
like how they later tried to just like
shoehorn like Sonic plays tennis
but Mario Mario did it so like don't
don't try to make Sonic cart Racers
which was I admit I like Mario
right you put him in a go-kart he's
already the fastest little hedgehog in
the world don't come in here oh sorry
about physics aren't involved don't come
in here yeah there's no speed involved
in this conversation you want to talk
that a hedgehog can't drive a car in
peace hey sorry all right and then that
kidnap his sidekick is one of the worst
it's an Abomination Sega made the same
mistake with Sonic
um his consoles they put out too many
Sonic games in a row too quickly where
they were which it seemed it seemed like
additional levels versus true sequels
and Nintendo did that initially with
Mario they made a Super Mario Brothers 2
it was considered so hard that they
never released it here until later then
they said we're gonna repurpose Doki
Doki Panic and making Super Mario
Brothers 2 which is what they did which
is a great game correct and then finally
they said this deserves a true sequel
uh and they made Super Mario 3. what
about this never had a movie right Sonic
has two right now I think he said the
first one lost 100 million dollars but
let's talk about the Mario that's not
true
this one is getting panned because who's
doing Donkey Kong's voice Jack Black oh
no Jack Black's Bowser I'm sorry okay
Bowser yeah that's got to be a tightrope
there walking there yeah
I hate Chris let's talk about the
blowback
it's about to blowback for Chris Pratt
not to use the Equinox offensive
Japanese stereo yes he's getting
blowback for not doing the voice the
offensive uh Italian voice it's me yeah
yeah well here's one because everybody
wants it here's nobody's offended here's
where I he he they did not use him
because of that they didn't use them
because they wanted to load this thing
up with celebrities they got Seth Rogen
as Donkey Kong they got Charlie Dave's
Luigi they got it but he's still gonna
put Chris bracket is still winning to me
yeah just have the guy do it just have
the guy that's been doing it that guy
helped make Mario who he is Mario the
personality that everybody fell in love
Nintendo if you're watching and we know
that you are well yeah you could have
just gave it to the guy
did not want to see the movie yeah
a lot of guys asked for like uh
courtside seats but yeah we can we'll
see if we can pull some stuff we uh we
should go to the phones yeah the phones
what fun at 40. let's go to the phone so
we can take our time reading some
comments here all right it's what we say
sorry when we go to Twitter we say go to
the phone okay cool the poll is up on
Twitter and that's live commenting I'm
having so much fun I love it I'd love
you to come back
this one
is a piece of dogs
yeah how old were you when it came out
say I'm in the same area yeah well I
will tell you right now if you watch it
now it might be campy enough to be like
this is terribly good oh yeah sure does
Luigi come into play here at all no
absolutely because because Tails and
Knuckles Tails and Knuckles don't come
into play okay Diddy's not coming in
okay okay I'm I'm seeing some of this is
he a Bastion to Mario or is he like
somebody just waiting for Mario to fail
no he's player too
like this yeah
Super Mario Brothers Mario Brothers I
know they're Brothers but I could point
to a lot of brothers who you know look
at oasis
by the way I'll say this too Sonic still
manages as does Mario to drop
a good game still yeah sonic Frontiers
just came out and it's a good game there
we go um Odyssey came out it was a good
game yeah yeah they saw Luigi's uh
Castle or whatever the hell it was uh
yeah that was a great game too okay I've
been crazy about that was GameCube yeah
look a game the original was game it was
a little hard to control I know it was
Mario Super Mario sucks oh it's a great
game let's take all the action out of it
RPGs to the masses
about there was RPGs yeah but only dorks
played them no and then everyone's like
oh yeah oh you don't think Final Fantasy
was for dorks Tower at your way offer
bro you talking out of your [__]
you're close to this man you're talking
about here you're myopic you can't see
close to it yeah I played every game we
mentioned this morning
I'm seeing a lot of this is a tough
choice which I'm surprised yeah well I
thought it was going to be like Foxy if
you pick anything but Donkey Kong you're
a racist then mom ate all [__] Hitler
wow
[Music]
uh what's not to love about an angry
Barrel throwing ape who kidnaps a blonde
woman in his youth taking that every day
against an Italian plumber and a blue
Hedgehog
all right your words to God's ear sister
Mario is a SIM for a princess who can't
stay safe to save her own ass Donkey
Kong is a poop flinging monkey Sonic is
a baller collecting rings and emeralds
that's investment in his future I like
that comment that's not good
that's generated
no human being would have that thought
Sonic is trying to save the planet Mario
and Donkey dog are both just are oh just
simping over a girl who obviously isn't
interested and thinks they both smell
like well let's just for a minute uh
about Princess Peach
also a little bit full of us what's
under the bustle that's what I want to
know what's going on
princesses go she's at the bottom of a
list sisters are never high maintenance
yeah you're right yeah what a finicky
five kidnappings I'll give you a pass
yeah but number seven what were you
wearing what are you doing yeah you're
wearing banana scented undies what's
going on over there
she has just borderline personality
disorder yeah as soon as Mario's busy on
another antic she's like I know it'll
get him back who's the chick that got
kidnapped and then like fell in love
with the famous one oh yeah um
syndrome in real life yeah it was the
lady in the 70s she got like kidnapped
and she like started to side with the
Pampers oh yeah yeah he became famous
for it was it was it the Hearst yeah uh
um was Sonic was Sonic over donkey wait
hold on was Sonic was Sonic or Donkey
Kong ever played by Captain Lou Albano
conversation over I was in in a fight
yeah Donkey Kong is wiping you both of
course Mario Breeze fire
Mario isn't [__]
Sonic would Blaze ass on Mario and Sonic
has a at least has a chance again
all you want once I get my mitts on you
I'm smacking you so fast that I could
make time spin I could Sonic is The
Flash you know where the game has
settled this he's what is he I mean come
on I don't know what he is nothing I'm a
union
yeah yeah he's a local I got the five
families behind me
he's like God yeah Carmine I'm
untouchable is what I am yeah uh Roger
Craig Smith deserves all the love with
Sonic that's the guy that or no no it's
not read it read the next one Donkey
Kong Country destroys every Mario game
don't even get me started on Donkey Kong
64. well I'm not saying 60 words enough
good games Sonic is for the kid that
made
Sonic is for the kid they made sit at
the back of the class when he forgot his
meds yeah
before there was Adderall for children
there was Sonic well Donkey Kong is the
only one who went from Full villain to
full hero arguably the most character
development of all three that is an
excellent point the younger siblings are
going to get PTSD this episode how does
a gorilla named after another animal or
a cracked out Hedgehog come close
all right can you scroll down a little
bit there was one that looked really
good just a little bit more a little
more uh Italy should replace its flag
with a picture of Mario Japan has downed
was has done more for Italy than pizza
tourism and The Godfather combined PS
what kind of pants does Mario wear denim
denim denim
yeah oh denim denim denim yeah I didn't
know what that meant and I still got it
in the moment yeah you know some might
say I should be a broadcaster or
something like that you guys make it
look so easy they think they can get in
the ring yeah exactly I'm not seeing any
funny ones really I mean some Zelda like
nothing like that Zelda I know uh I mean
there was others cheated on me with both
an Italian man and a giant gorilla I
vote Sonic let's give him the win follow
at golf in sports six nine Sonic is like
a little Ron Jeremy running around oh
yeah all right Sam here's how we do it
you plug everything you want to plug and
then we do a segment called Humble Pie
where we declare the winner and then
whoever wins has to say to the other two
I still love you I love you back that'll
be easy for me to say uh I will be at uh
helium Philadelphia April 19th I'll be
in uh Houston the 20th at the 21st I'll
be in Lafayette you can buy my book
Running the light that people love it's
a hell of a novel at Sam talent.com
t-a-l-l-e-n-t we're going to find all my
dates as well and follow me on Instagram
at Sam Talent
boom nice and simple you got a new
follower here you should it's the best
this is really fun
um he doesn't even talk to me like that
anymore yeah I remember when he used to
there's a new weird glasses guy in town
yeah
I know I'm tired of you like you got
tired of me that's okay I'm loyal I am
loyal sorry all right here we go yeah
Mario's gonna win obviously but six
thousand votes and okay pimps go Mario
himself
uh so it is a proper I mean I think it
would be that far apart Mario is 66.7
the winner
close but it's the way I thought it
would end up Sonic 18 Donkey Kong at
15.3 which you know everybody loves an
underdog maybe I'm the underground you
know I'm the underground player give us
the line I still love you guys what was
it yeah yeah I still love you both I
love you too you're supposed to say I
still love you you I I won he won yeah
so what oh sorry my bad I'm sorry I'm
old I'm all loopy but I still love you I
love you too
taste buds they come into the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two Fool's
gonna fight but only one food can be
right taste buds